what is the most beautiful or inspiring
idea you've come across in mathematics I
don't know man maybe it's an idea you've
explored in your videos maybe not what
like just gave you pause the most
beautiful idea small or big so I think
often the things that are most beautiful
are the ones that you have like an a
little bit of understanding of but
certainly not an entire understanding
it's a little bit of that mystery that
is what makes it beautiful almost a
moment of the discovery for you
personally almost just that leap of haha
moment so something that really caught
my eye I remember when I was little
there were these like um I think the
series was called like wooden books or
something these tiny little books that
would have just a very short description
of something on the left and then a
picture on the right I don't know who
they're meant for but maybe it's like
loosely children or something like that
but it can't just be children because of
some of the things that was describing
on the last page of one of them
somewhere tiny in there was this little
formula the on the left hand had a sum
over all of the natural numbers you know
it's like 1 over 1 to the s plus 1 over
2 to the s plus 1 over 3 to the S on and
on to the infinity then on the other
side had a product over all of the
primes and it was a certain thing I had
to do with all the primes and like any
good young math and Theseus tied
properly been indoctrinated with how
chaotic and confusing the primes are
which they are and seeing this equation
where on one site you have something
that's as understandable as you could
possibly get the counting numbers yes
and on the other side is all the prime
numbers it was like this whoa they're
related like this there's there's a
simple description that includes like
all the primes getting wrapped together
like this this is like the Euler product
for the zeta function as I like later
found out the equation itself
essentially encodes the fundamental
theorem of arithmetic that every number
can be expressed as a unique set of
primes
to me still there's I mean I certainly
don't understand this equation or this
function all that well the more I learn
about it the prettier it is
the idea that you can this is sort of
what gets you representations of primes
not in terms of Prime's themselves but
in terms of another set of numbers
they're like the non-trivial zeros of
the zeta function and again I'm very
kind of in over my head in a lot of ways
as I like try to get to understand it
but the more I do its it always leaves
enough mystery that it remains very
beautiful to me so whenever there's a
little bit of mystery just outside of
the understanding that and by the way
the process of learning more about it
how does that come about just your own
thoughts or are you reading reading yes
or is the process of visualization
itself revealing more to you visuals
help I mean in one time when I was just
trying to understand like analytic
continuation and playing around with
visualizing complex functions this is
what led to a video about this function
it's titled something like visualizing
the Riemann zeta-function
it's one that came about because I was
programming and tried to see what a
certain thing looked like and then I
looked at it I'm like well that's
elucidating and then I decided to make a
video about it but I mean you try to get
your hands on as much reading as you can
you you know in this case I think if
anyone wants to start to understand it
if they have like a math background of
some like they studied some in college
or something like that like the
Princeton Companion to math has a really
good article on analytic number theory
and that itself has a whole bunch of
references and you know anything has
more references and it gives you this
like tree to start calling through and
like you know you try to understand I
try to understand things visually as I
go that's not always possible but it's
very helpful when it does you recognize
when there's common themes like in this
case
cousins of the Fourier transform I come
into play and you realize oh it's
probably pretty important to have deep
intuitions of the fourier transform even
if it's not explicitly mentioned in like
these texts and you try to get a sense
of what the common players are but I'll
emphasize again like I feel very in over
my head when I try to understand the
exact relation between like the zeros of
the Riemann zeta function and how they
relate to the distribution of primes I
definitely understand it better than I
did a year ago I definitely understand
it 1/100 as well as the experts on the
matter do I assume but the slow path
towards getting theirs
it's fun it's charming and like to your
question very beautiful and the beauty
is in the what in the journey versus the
destination well it's thing doesn't feel
arbitrary I think that's a big part is
that you have these unpredictable none
yeah these very unpredictable patterns
were these intricate properties of like
a certain function but at the same time
it doesn't feel like humans ever made an
arbitrary choice in studying this
particular thing so you know it feels
like you're speaking to patterns
themselves or nature itself
that's a big part of it I think things
that are too arbitrary it's just hard
for those to feel beautiful because and
this is sort of what the word contrived
is meant to apply to right and the one
they're not arbitrary means it could be
you can have a clean abstraction an
intuition that allows you to comprehend
it well to one of your first questions
it makes you feel like if you came
across another intelligent civilization
that they'd be studying the same thing
it may be with different notation yeah
but yeah like that's what I think you
talk to that other civilization they're
probably also studying the zeros of the
Riemann zeta function or it's like some
variant there up that is like a clearly
equivalent cousin or something like that
but that's probably on their on their
docket
you